my name is Thomas Peterson I'm a
software engineer at pet and it is my
great pleasure to welcome the first
speaker on stage she is Reiko akamoto
and she's a methodologist at Bria
Research Institute give her a
[Applause]
hand hi
everyone just to wait for a few people
to trickle
in all right so one of the most
important parts of my late childhood and
Adolescence growing up in Canada was
reality shows on cable
television and whether it Evol it
involved 11 teams of two in a race
around the world or an up incoming Chef
fighting against an Iron Chef based on a
secret ingredient I just could not get
enough of this unscripted chaos
unfolding in front of me and during the
early days of the pandemic when I was
spending a questionable amount of time
on YouTube uh one day I stumbled down a
recommendation of rabbit hole and
reunited with another show that I
remembered watching growing up called
neat now neat was this dramatic makeover
series that was on home and garden
television in which a professional
design uh organizer named Helen uh would
help a person or
family with cluttered Living
Spaces devise solutions to better
organize their lives and possessions
more
effectively now as someone with
experience performing data analysis in
both Academia and the public sector I
just could not help but to notice that
many of the principles of home organiz
ization are actually applicable to file
management so for example whether it's
physical or digital clutter in our space
is usually clutter in our minds as well
and more importantly clutter shouldn't
be taking away our focus and creativity
nor should it be blocking our way to
success that being said unfortunately
tips about file management can can often
be presented as this mixed bag of ideas
without a unifying narrative or even
worse file management itself can be
entirely overlooked in favor of arguably
more exciting topics like machine
learning and data
visualization so my goal over the next
15 minutes or so is to draw comparisons
between home organization and file
management to better illustrate that
keeping your space clean clean and tidy
is going to save you a lot of time down
the
road so as I was watching these clips um
uploaded onto YouTube I noticed that the
show often featured a client that was
struggling to declutter either their
living room and dining combo or studio
apartment now what was common to these
spaces was that without distinct rooms
separated by walls boundaries became
blurred and as a result it was really
unclear as to where one activity ended
and another one began for example I'm
talking about you know a dining table
potentially turning into a secondary
office desk does that sound familiar uh
or an overflowing box of business
receipts somehow sitting on a kitchen
counter is that familiar as well not
sure uh but to address this issue the
host would begin by moving existing
furniture or adding these these room
dividers to create dedicated spaces that
were conducive to a specific activity so
I'm talking about you know a space for
eating and another space for working and
I think the digital analog to this kind
of
clutter is a documents folder that has
just become this Dumping Ground for ad
hoc analysis plots meeting minutes and
so much
more and we can begin to address this
mess by organizing our work into self
contain projects where each project is a
folder that contains all the files
relevant to a particular piece of work
so this involves the input data any R
scripts and their Associated results and
furthermore any R code that's going to
be sitting in this folder you're going
to write it as if it will be run from a
fresh R session with its working
directory pointed to the Project's
route and this meth method of
compartmentalization conveniently allows
us to move our project or folder from
one location on our computer to another
or onto an entirely different machine
while ensuring that the code is most
likely going to work in its new
location and I think we can further
Elevate this method of
compartmentalization by using our Studio
Projects so if you're new to our Studio
Projects when a new project is is
created either in a brand new or
existing directory our studio creates a
project file within the directory which
is then used to store the settings that
are specific to that project so uh if we
ever want to return to the project after
taking a small break we can just open up
that project file and in the IDE we'll
see that the current working directory
is set to the project
directory uh the file browser is pointed
at the project
folder uh any previously edited files
are restored into the editor
tabs and uh other R Studio settings such
as active tabs and splitter positions
are going to be restored to exactly
where they were the last time the
project was
closed and
furthermore excuse me um a new R session
is started and this aligns with our idea
of self-contained projects that we
discussed
earlier and this setup makes it easier
to jump back into a specific analysis um
after you've taken a break from from it
or to juggle multiple analyses at once
without disorder and to tie this all
back to home organization I think it's
just uh I think it's similar to how it's
a lot easier to go from practicing the
piano to cooking dinner when you have a
established dedicated spaces for each
activity rather than having to move
Dirty Laundry off of the piano or that
box of uh business receipts off of your
kitchen counter before doing what it is
that you actually want to be
doing and at some point in each episode
on neat the host Helen often encouraged
the clients to let go of duplicates and
items that they're just holding on to
just in case to reduce clutter and
understandably on the show some people
found it challenging to let go of these
sentimental items you know this could
have been like a pre-teen refusing to
part ways with their collection of
stuffed animals or um a parent uh going
through outgrown B baby clothes and
really trying to carefully choose an
item from each Milestone and I think as
data analysts we can cling on to files
in a similar fashion especially because
data analysis often involves iteration
and revision to go from this initial
idea to the final
deliverable and without a good system in
place for tracking how something evolves
over time projects can easily turn Messy
as you see up
here now to address this mess one thing
that we can do is to adopt Version
Control and this allows us or gives us
the option to revert selected files back
to a previous state compare changes over
time see who monifi something and when
all without having to keep every version
of the file further reducing the amount
of visual clutter that we have on our
machines and on the show Once the
unnecessary clutter was removed from the
home the host would then set up an
organizational system that was suited to
the client's lifestyle and and the
possessions that they
held specifically um when using storage
bins the host Helen would make it really
easy to find things in the future by
leaving no doubt as to what was inside
each one of these containers so we're
talking about using transparent clear
containers or using the label printer
and printing out a label for each one of
these boxes and in a similar fashion I
think as analysts it's crucial for us to
adopt uh directory structure that
matches the type of project that we're
working
on so for an ad hog analysis that I have
on the left that might mean creating a
subfolder for raw data another one for
the code used in analysis maybe another
one to keep the respective outputs
meanwhile on the right hand side for an
r package uh the package development
conventions May encourage us to create a
subdirectory for for function
definitions another one for unit tests
another one for vignettes and so on but
regardless of what kind of project we're
working on whether that's ad hoc
analyses or an art package um going back
to this idea of leaving no doubt as to
what's inside each container we should
always consider adding a read me to the
project route which tells other people
why our project is useful what they can
do with it and how they can use it and
if there's a lot of content to squeeze
into one read me file I think that um
invites us to consider whether it's
appropriate to place additional readme
files in the
subdirectories and speaking from
personal experience um at my previous
workplace we had a folder on a shared
drive that contained many many many ad
hoc analysis um and or many many rmd
files and each file was uh for a
particular uh piece of ad hoc analysis
and a colleague of mine suggested
creating a lookup table which summarized
the content of each file to make it
easier to refer back to the previous
analysis when
needed so um I took her uh suggestion
and I wrote a code snippet to
automatically parse the yaml metadata
from each rmd file uh that was sitting
in the analysis subdirectory to at this
lookup table which was then uh embedded
into the readme file of the analysis
subdirectory so here I'm sharing this
reworked version of the code that I just
talked about uh so this is a reworked
version of the code for Cordo documents
and I'm beginning by um defining a
function with the help of the Cordo
packages Cordo inspect uh to retrieve
the metadata of interest for our given
file and then I map this function that I
just defined extract metadata out to all
the qmd files found in a given directory
to generate this tble that you see on
the bottom that allows me to quickly
inspect the file name uh the title and
subtitle that's sitting inside the yaml
uh metadata component of each Cordo
document very quickly
and uh if you want you can then add this
tible to to the readme.md of a
particular subdirectory that you might
want to provide more information
on and once again going back to the show
so once the host helped clear the
Clutter and figured out what kind of
organizational system was best suited to
the client's lifestyle and possessions
she further elevated the space by
ensuring consistency and I think a great
example of this is using matching
hangers to reduce visual clutter and to
make a closet easier to navigate and
this can be a little bit more difficult
when you have a mix of metal and plastic
hangers it maybe some of those hangers
that you get from free um for free from
the dry cleaners and in the world of
file management I think this messiness
resembles not having a proper framework
in place for naming our
files um but through adopting a file
naming convention we can further reduce
the amount of visual clutter on our
machines and also make it easier for us
to find things in the future and Jenny
Brian uh who is also at this conference
I believe has shared some great
resources on file naming conventions so
for the next little bit I'm going to be
drawing from her expertise and I'll
share the three features that constitute
a good file
name first um a good file name should be
machine readable so we're talking about
avoiding special uh special characters
uh avoiding spaces and also being
mindful of case sensitivity and this is
all so that our file names can play well
with our machine's inherent search
functionality and here I'm focusing on
the intentional use of underscores to
allow for the easy recovery of metadata
using glob patterns or regular
Expressions down the road the second Fe
Fe of a good file name is that it should
be human readable and here I'm using
hyphens to delimit words to make the
file names a little bit easier for us to
read and I'm also focusing on using
descriptive and non-generic keywords uh
this is so that I can provide somewhat
of a preview in terms of the content and
purpose of the file the third
feature is that the file name should
allow for the files to be uh arranged in
a useful way while assuming alpha
numeric ordering so here in the top half
of the slide I'm using the iso 8601
standard for dates uh when I want my
files to be arranged in chronological
order and in the bottom half I'm making
sure to left pad the numbers with zero
when I want my scripts to be in logical
order or the order in which they're
called in an analysis workflow and left
padding would Z prevent situations like
the number 10 written as one Z appearing
before uh two in a list maybe that you
have experienced that in the past while
naming files so uh we covered a lot of
ground so I think it's a good moment to
recap what we discussed and I hope over
the past 15 minutes I was able to
convince you that by applying techniques
are shared on an home organization show
such as creating dedicated zones uh
reducing redundancy setting up
customized Storage Solutions and
pursuing visual
consistency you can create a Serene
relaxing workspace that facilitates
reproducible analysis is inviting to
other collaborators including your
future self and exudes
professionalism so whether you're an
instructor looking to revise their file
management lesson plan or maybe you are
someone who wants to inspire their
colleagues to reconsider file management
practices in the workplace I hope this
narrative provided you with some
inspiration today uh thank you for
listening and I hope you enjoy the rest
of the
conference thank you so much Rao so
we'll have time for a few questions um
first one how do you encourage ongoing
good file
management um one thing that I caught
myself doing today I was trying to
upload um this a copy of the slide to my
GitHub and I I realized that the default
file name for the PDF wasn't so good and
I was really tired because it was like
9:00 last night and I was like God you
know I'll I'll just leave it as is but
then I kind of thought to myself you
know I should be a good role model and
and probably give it a better file uh
file name so I think it starts by um by
by you um applying and demonstrating
what you are trying to convince your
colleagues uh in terms of um making them
do exactly what it is that you want them
to follow yeah fantastic um another
question so um in a home there is often
need for like a a draw that is messy so
that everything else can be un
messy is there a similar like idea for
files um hm like like a Dumping Ground
that kind of has to be there um yeah in
in the past I think involuntarily We've
Ended up in situations where folders
like that have existed but then I think
you also then have to be responsible for
setting up a reasonable timeline as to
when you want to go back um and Resort
delete things from that Dumping Ground
folder us to to to Really keep it as
like a temporary solution as opposed to
something that is going to you know
consist consistently live within their
team's work space fantastic thank you so
much REO
[Applause]
thanks